we have the equation negative is 16 is
equal to x over 4 plus 2 and we need to
solve for X so really just need to
isolate the X variable on one side of
this equation and the best way to do
that is first to isolate it isolate this
whole X / 4 term from all of the other
terms so in order to do that let's get
rid of this - and the best way to get
rid of that - is to subtract it but if
we want to subtract it from the
right-hand side we also have to subtract
it from the left-hand side because this
is an equation if this is equal to that
anything we do to that we also have to
do to this so let's subtract 2 from both
sides so you subtract 2 from the right
subtract 2 from the left and we get on
the left-hand side negative 16 minus 2
is negative 18 and then that is equal to
X / 4x over 4 and then we have positive
2 minus 2 which is just going to be 0 so
we don't even have to write that I could
write just a plus 0 but I think that's a
little unnecessary and so we have
negative 18 is equal to x over 4 and our
whole goal here is to isolate the X to
solve for the X and the best way we
could do that if we have x over 4 here
if we multiply that by 4 we're just
going to have an X so we can multiply
that by 4 but once again this is an
equation anything you do the right-hand
side you have to do to the left-hand
side and vice versa so if we multiply
the right-hand side by 4 we also have to
multiply the left-hand side by 4 so we
get 4 times negative 18 is equal to x
over 4 times 4 the x over 4 times 4 that
cancels out you divide something by 4
and multiply by 4 you're just going to
be left with an X and on the other side
4 times negative 18 let's see that's 40
well let's just write it out so 18 times
4 if we were to multiply 18 times 4 4
times 8 is 32 4 times 1 is 4 plus 1 is
72 but this is negative 18 times 4 so
it's negative 72 so X is equal to
negative 72 and if we
want to check it we can just substitute
it back into that original equation so
let's do that let's substitute let's
substitute this into the original
equation so the original equation was
negative 16 is equal to instead of
writing X I'm going to write negative 72
is equal to negative 72 over 4 over 4
plus 2 let's see if this is actually
true so this right-hand side simplifies
to negative 72 divided by 4 we already
know that that is negative 18 so this is
equal to negative 18 plus 2 this is what
the equation becomes and then the
right-hand side negative 18 plus 2
that's negative 16 so it all comes out
through this right-hand side when X is
equal to negative 72 does indeed equal
negative 16